c'est la fin de 15 ans de procédures
l'état a donc décidé de ne pas faire
appel du jugement rendu début juillet
par le tribunal arbitral dans l' affaire
qui opposait le crédit lyonnais à
bernard tapie
ce dernier devrait donc toucher au moins
2 185 millions d'euros d'indemnisations
christelle meyrals bernard tapie peut
sourire
il a définitivement gagné son combat
judiciaire contre le crédit lyonnais
avec une indemnisation record de 285
millions d'euros
l'état ne déposera pas de recours contre
la décision qui donne raison à l'homme
d'affaires le volet judiciaire est donc
clos mais pas la polémique
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale se penchera sur le
dossier
début septembre nous avons décidé de
recourir à ces auditions justement pour
nous faire un point de vue et puis
surtout faire en sorte que les choses
soient le plus transparente possible
dans cette affaire tout comme en cent
quatre-vingt-treize bernard tapie
devient ministre de la ville sous
françois mitterrand pour éviter la
confusion des genres l'homme d'affaires
demande au crédit lyonnais de revendre
adidas la banque vend la marque pour 315
millions d'euros
mais dans le même temps elles négocient
en secret et revend adidas à robert
louis dreyfus pour 700 millions
le lyonnais en poche la plus value dans
le doubs de bernard tapie l'homme
d'affaires crie au scandale
commence alors une saga judiciaire mais
pas de jugement définitif en quinze ans
de procédure les deux camps font alors
appel à un tribunal arbitral composé
entre autres de pierre mazeaud un ancien
du conseil constitutionnel ce type de
tribunal est souvent utilisé pour les
contentieux entre sociétés ou d'état
mais dont l' affaire tapie le recours à
cette procédure et comptait 106 tic
notamment de l'ancienne magistrate eva
joly qui a instruit plusieurs dossiers
top secret de l'instruction
c'est un usage non démocratique la
justice arbitrale
elle n'est pas transparente elle n'est
pas publique
vous ne pourrez pas aller à les lire vos
journalistes
cette sentence arbitrale c'est donc une
justice privée payée et qui pour moi est
contestable
les politiques se sont saisis de la
faire le canard enchaîné révèle que la
ministre christine lagarde est intervenu
en faveur du tribunal arbitral
françois bayroux lui accuse nicolas
sarkozy d'avoir favorisé bernard tapie
en remerciement de son soutien pendant
la présidentielle
c'est une chose qui s'est jamais
produite qui est extrêmement graves et
lourdes conséquences
alors que la plus haute juridiction
française la cour de cassation avait dit
qu'il n'y avait pas lieu indemnités donc
c'est une effusion dans laquelle le
gouvernement le pouvoir et le président
de la république à n'en pas douter ont
été impliqués et dont ils vont devoir
maintenant s'expliquer devant les
français
du côté de l'ump on fait valoir que
françois bayroux et proche de jean
peyrelevade ancien président du lyonnais
hostiles à bernard tapie
l'indemnisation de l'homme d'affaires
pourrait atteindre au final 400 millions
d'euros après réactualisation des
intérêts mais une fois payés les dettes
et surtout le fisc il devrait rester à
bernard tapie
environ 35 millions d'euros